[Musique]
la molécule d'hémoglobine donc qui lui
permet de faire ça c'est une molécule en
fait qui est géante qui est capable de
lier 40 fois plus d'oxygène que nous
aimons globine à nouveau c'est donc en
fait cette molécule d'hémoglobine c'est
un peu la petite bouteille d'oxygène en
fait du ver marin
[Musique]
la grève c'est une course contre la
montre en fait quand vous déconnecter un
coeur vous avez quatre heures entre le
moment où vous les connecter au moment
où vous allez le transplanter est donc
le but de ça c'est en fait de donner de
l'oxygène aux greffons qui lui
permettent d'attendre en fait la
connexion chez le receveur est donc
d'apporter un greffon envie
[Musique]
je crois qu'on peut dire que c'est une
révolution parce que dans le monde de la
transplantation et dans le monde un
petit peu plus fermés de la conservation
des organes on n'a pas eu de progrès
thérapeutique depuis des années on n'a
pas réellement de moyens de protéger les
greffons il ya un enjeu majeur puisque
plus on va protéger les greffons pu ils
vont probablement
fonctionner longtemps chez le receveur
[Musique]